welcome back everyone okay what we're
gonna do today is simulate the logistic
map so this is a discrete-time system xk
plus 1 equals beta times xk times 1
minus xk and we're gonna simulate this
in matlab and what we're going to do is
increase this beta parameter so we're
going to go from beta equals 0 all the
way up to 4 and we're going to get some
really cool diagrams of what happens
with the system ok so I just want to
show you kind of how to plot this and
how to work with this in MATLAB it's
kind of a fun example that you've
probably seen a few times before and so
I want to show you how to code this up
ok so the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to create a vector called
X vowels so we're going to store all of
our X values in this increasing size
vector
I should probably what am I going to do
I'm gonna walk through this beta
parameter so I'm going to I'm going to
increase my beta and simulate this
dynamical system and watch where these
points go and I'm going to do that for
every increasing value of beta so I'm
going to say for beta equals let's say 0
in increments of 0.1 all the way up to 4
what we're going to do is I'll just
print beta to the screen so that it'll
it'll count down here through beta now
what we're going to do is we're going to
start with an initial condition usually
I start with an initial condition X
naught equals 0.5 and what we're going
to do is we're going to we want to know
what the what the steady-state behavior
is not the transients so I'm going to
take this initial condition point 5 and
I'm gonna run it through here a bunch of
times maybe it'll be there will be a
fixed point and it'll just map to the
same thing over and over maybe it will
be there will be a periodic orbit and
it'll bounce back and forth between a
couple of X values or maybe it'll be
chaotic and it'll go all over the place
but what I want to do is I want to take
this x value and iterate it through a
bunch of times
so that it hits steady-state and then I
want to store a few thousand of the
steady state values because it's going
to look really cool okay so we're gonna
say X old equals 0.5 and for I equals 1
to let's say 2000 I'm going to do this
two thousand times to get rid of the
transience I'm gonna say X nu equals x
old minus X old squared times beta and
at the end of that iteration X old
equals x NATO so notice here I'm just
saying X minus x squared times beta so
this is a little bit faster to compute
and after every time my old vector my
new vector becomes the old vector I plug
it in I get my new vector and this
iterates over and over this is a really
cheesy way of just saying XK plus 1
equals some function of XK and at the
end of the time step XK plus 1 becomes
you know my K increases 1 ok so this is
just going to be let me say transient
I'm just gonna run this transient I'm
not going to save any of this data it's
just going to evolve onto the attractor
and then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to start saving the data and I'm
gonna iterate more okay so now what I'm
going to do is how do I want to do this
I'm going to in fact save it until it
gets arbitrarily close to itself again
okay so for I equals 1 to 1,000 I'm
gonna say X nu equals x old minus X old
squared times beta X old equals x nu and
now I'm actually going to save these
values so I'm gonna save the beta value
and I'm going to save the x value so I'm
gonna say X Belles the first value
length of xml's plus 1 so I'm going to
add 1 to the length and I'm gonna store
in that current beta value and then I'm
going to have
ex vowels to lengths of X vowels let's
just go here and it's already increased
the length in this line so I don't have
to do it again here this is going to
equal X new so basically this X bowels
structure the first I guess Row is going
to be all of the beta values and the
second row is going to be all of these X
values and what I'm going to eventually
be able to do is make a cool scatterplot
and it's going to be this bifurcation
diagram of the logistic map that you've
seen before
okay now what I'm gonna do is I don't
want to save if I have a really boring
solution where it's just a fixed point
and X nu is equal to X old I don't want
this to run through a thousand iteration
so I'm gonna break it if it gets
arbitrarily close to itself so what I
want to do is I want to say X steady
state equals x nu and if my new solution
- my steady state solution is less than
0.001 then I'm gonna break the loop so
I'm only gonna keep going if I'm more if
I'm more than 0.001 different than my my
kind of initial condition up here and
then I think I can end I can end through
my beta loop and now what I can do is I
can make a cool plot of all of these
values okay so I'm gonna plot X vowels
to :
I'm gonna flip this thing upside down
actually why don't I just do it like
this I'll do an X valves one colon here
why don't I do it in order okay I want
line width 0.1 I want marker size 1.2 I
want color to be white which is I think
one one one hopefully and then I'm going
to set my GCA color to be
black and my X color to be whites my Y
color to be white and I'm gonna set my
color GCF to be color black
okay let's hope this runs I'm gonna run
it no errors it wasn't super fast I
don't know if you saw how fast I went
through all those betas and here what we
have this is the beta parameter and
these are the X values that got stored
okay so now maybe I should I'll just do
an X label this is beta and Y label are
all of my X points runs super fast
okay and so what we see is that as we
increase beta from zero to one the fixed
point there's one fixed point and it's
at x equals zero so it basically means
if beta is less than one
whenever I plug into here is going to go
to zero very quickly so after that
transient period everything died out and
went to zero and I get this this zero
here and then as I increase beta from
one to about three I get a fixed point a
single fixed point this iterates and it
eventually converges to this fixed point
for that beta parameter and then stays
there for every future iteration and
then it beta three you see that now I
get two solutions and what's going to
happen is the X is going to bounce back
and forth between these two solutions
this is called a periodic orbit where
basically the population is bouncing
back and forth for every generation it's
bigger than smaller than bigger than
smaller as I increase the beta more you
can see that now this period doubles and
I have four solutions so now that's a
quasi periodic orbit so I'm going to
bounce back and forth between these and
as you crank up that parameter beta even
more between about three point five and
four the system goes chaotic and you get
this really rich interesting attractor
where the X is kind of spending a lot of
time just bouncing around in these
regions okay so I'm going to do a couple
of things now and plot the first thing
I'm going to do is I want to flip the
order of these
because I want it to look like cool
mountains okay and I'm gonna do what do
I want to do and Val what is n Val -
okay like four - yeah four - all of this
let's run this okay so now I basically
turn this thing up on its head and now I
should change the labels - while a bowl
and X label and now I had this cool
thing that looks kind of like a mountain
I really should flip my flip my y-axis
because now the labels are wrong this
should be four and this should be three
but we'll go with it
in fact let me just turn my labels how
do I do that that's not too hard I'm
gonna set GCA X tick x ticks to be zero
one two three four and my X tick labels
to be four three two one zero
okay this might crash my computer
because it says what does it say there's
no x ticks property there's probably
just an x tick that works okay crap but
I changed my X ticks not my Y ticks so
all I have to do is change this to Y
okay so this is one of the joys of live
coding is that you get to see all of the
errors I make but you also hopefully
will get to learn how to do this
yourself okay so notice now I because I
flipped this now I'm flipping my Y tick
marks
so I'm relabeling them to go from 0 to 4
instead of instead of going up and now
you get this kind of cool mountain
looking structure here in this
bifurcation diagram so one thing I'm
going to do that I think is going to be
interesting is let's not cut out the
transients okay so I removed all the
transient here because I thought it
would be cool to show you let's see I'm
gonna comment that out so it's actually
not going to remove the transient
anymore and we're going to plot all of
that transients so when I start from 0.5
it's gonna have to iterate some time
before it converges on to those fixed
points now X nu equals let's do that and
now you can see this kind of cool
transient iteration so essentially after
one iteration X jumps to 0 if beta 0 but
then as beta increases as beta increases
notice now that X jumps eventually what
am I trying to say you can see all these
lines here these are the the iterations
that it takes for X to go to 0 so it
jumps from from 0.5 to here then to here
then here then here then here then here
and it takes some time for it to iterate
to that fixed point and similarly for it
to iterate onto this fixed point line
and so it's a little messy so this is
why I cut out the transient cuz I just
wanted you to see this steady-state
behavior okay so let's go back and keep
that transient I want this to look a
little cooler so I think what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to use an even smaller
value of beta 0.01 I'm going to cut out
more transients so 5,000 and I'm gonna
run this thing for 10,000 points so this
is gonna take a lot longer I hope in
fact this runs in a reasonable amount of
time and one thing I'm also gonna do is
I'm going to set my Y limits I'll do
that later okay now you can see my beta
takes some time to spin up and this is a
lot more filled in so now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to set my Y limits my
y Y limits from 3 to 4 I think that what
I want to do that wasn't good
I want to set my why limits for the zero
to one perfect okay
so I've essentially zoomed into this
beta region from three to four where all
the interesting stuff was happening and
you can see remember it was just a
single fixed point up here and now it's
split into this periodic orbit and it's
split again into this quasi periodic
orbit and then eventually after a few
more period doublings it gets fully a
chaotic okay so anyway it's pretty easy
to simulate these iterations just with a
for loop usually I get rid of the
transients and look at the steady state
behavior and if you plot this in a cool
enough you know if you transpose it and
plot it and zoom in you can make these
beautiful pictures which I think look
like mountains okay so I called these
mathematical mountains you can make
really cool art like this you can make
cooler colors I mean why don't we just
try that instead of plotting it in white
why don't we just make it what is it
RGB so let's make it super blue okay so
like point two point two let's just run
this and see how cool it looks and then
I'll do my while in and you can see this
really really neat kind of blue mountain
structure okay so it looks really cool
very easy to simulate and it's one of
the things I think is interesting is you
know this is a crude model for
population dynamics you could derive
this and why why this is a good model
for population dynamics basically
because I could start with XK plus 1
equals beta XK that would just be like
exponential growth at some rate you know
beta and then you realize there the
earth doesn't have infinite resources so
there's some carrying capacity and if X
gets large enough where you know the
carrot that the large the biggest size
of population I can have is one when I
get large enough I should start
multiplying it by something that gets
closer and closer to zero so this
basically is a model where in x over
time you grow exponentially until you
get close to your carrying capacity of 1
and then you eventually kind of roll off
that's at least how you could derive the
logistic map very simply for a
population dynamic but then what's
interesting is as you get this different
increasing rate beta so maybe the system
grows really really really fast or
really really really slow you can get
these very very different behaviors so
these are the behaviors you can get at a
particular value of beta and you can see
that the behavior is very different as
you increase beta and alarmingly as you
make your growth rate faster and faster
and faster your system gets more and
more chaotic so it bounces around it's
more erratic and so this maybe should
give us some indication at least in this
crude model that having you know
breakneck population growth really big
beta is a bad idea okay because you get
this kind of chaotic behavior here okay
so very easy to simulate discrete time
dynamical systems in MATLAB you can make
beautiful pictures please play around
with this and try it yourself okay thank
you